hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his life of aristipus located in book
six of his lives of the philosopher
diagonist layer taste is going to give
us a summary of the doctrines of
aristipus and his serenaic school and he
tells us quite a few things that have to
do with the sage or the wise person and
with several other things that we
typically see associated with the sage
or wise person in the various schools of
ancient philosophy namely virtue and
happiness and there's a little bit less
of a let's call it Ironclad necessary
connection between wisdom or sagehood
and these other matters there's a little
bit of
wiggle room we might say so the first
thing to talk about is he you know he
reveals to us that they think there are
sages there are wise people and this is
a you know genuine question in ancient
philosophy are there people who we can
say not only are you know very
intelligent and wise both in theoretical
and practical manners but also display
this through how they live their life
and what it is about their life that's
different from other people that allows
us to say yeah that person really has it
put together and you know the stoics
quite famously coming later will say you
know the sage is like a legendary
phoenix only one in every 500 years well
that's not the case for the serenax in
part because their idea of sagehood is
you know the benchmarks for it are a
little bit lower and so it's easier for
people to uh make it into sagehood you
could say and
one of the doctrines that really
illustrates this
is that they do not accept the idea that
every wise person every every Sage lives
pleasantly hideous Zayn and every
foolish person painfully so you know
typically What what schools would say is
you know the sages whatever it is that's
best they get it and then foolish people
at the opposite whatever is worse they
get it right and aristipus and the
Syrian acts are saying nah that's only
for the most part or that's a general
thing that we can say Kata told
playstone in Greek for the most part is
another way of Translating that right so
if you do live in a wise way you're
probably more likely to live a pleasant
life but there's no complete guarantees
in stupid people fools obstinate people
people who believe in misinformation
every once in a while they get lucky and
so you know there's there's an
acknowledgment of the role that what the
Ancients called Fortune plays in
our happiness or our pleasure as we're
going to see happiness and pleasure
aren't exactly the same thing
for the crane ax and then they go on to
discuss some of the things that
typically are associated with sages
namely Prudence or practical wisdom
virtue and friendship so you know they
say that Prudence is a good thing but
desirable not in itself but on account
of its consequences what what it brings
to us the things literally that come out
of it that develop out of it and what
would that be running your life in a
decent way and we can look at aristipus
himself as an example of that you know
you can pursue Pleasures don't allow
Pleasures to master you that's one prime
example being confident in whatever
situation he winds up which he says is a
product of philosophy and we could talk
about other things we can look at the
choices that aristipus makes the
selections and the things that he looks
down upon as we've talked about
elsewhere what about virtue so typically
in ancient philosophy virtue
Excellence is viewed as something quite
important the serenax once again
have a different sort of viewpoint on it
he says that for example some of the
virtues are found even in the foolish
you know so a stupid person a foolish
person they're not going to be wise
obviously but you know they might be
just because they just they do the right
thing when they're supposed to even
though they're not quite sure why
they're supposed to be doing it they
could be temperate they could be to some
degree courageous right it's not just
the wise for whom this is a possibility
and they also say something else quite
interesting about virtue bodily training
10 somatican
escasing contributes
to developing virtue right so it's not
that going to the gym is going to
automatically make you virtuous but
some bodily training some training of
the body in particularly in relation to
its pleasures and pains is important
friendship uh you know something that's
quite good in life they say that you
know friendship is good but we make
friends from interested motives we make
friends because they're going to help us
out they're going to contribute to our
pleasure or help us to avoid certain
pain so friendship is not a good in
itself for the serenax age either and
you could extend that to relationships
in general
there's a few other things that are said
very interesting about the uh Sage from
the perspective of this school so they
will feel pain and the term there is
actually lupus thigh uh which is you
know the term that we usually see for
pain the serenax at least in this
summary use a couple other terms uh you
know the ponone which is you know toil
or work algaace pain in other respects
but they're going to feel pain and
they're also going to feel fear uh
Phobos thigh and why because these are
natural to human beings fusi Coast is
how they'll feel them which is as human
beings that have bodies that have
certain instincts that respond to things
but there's a very important distinction
that's drawn here there are some things
now the translation here is a little bit
misleading it says that they will will
not give way to Envy or lava
superstition
it literally says they won't feel Envy
meta phonation
nor will they feel we could call it love
erotic desire uh
nor will they be subject to Superstition
all of these are verbs they won't fall
into it they won't they won't even like
go a little ways into it and why not
because each of these is based on
something that the sage is going to
avoid and this is where philosophy can
be helpful they're based on empty
opinion Kano dogs this is a another term
that's used quite often by other schools
of ancient philosophy including the
other main hedonist School the
epicureans who say that all sorts of
foolish desires that we have are based
on similarly empty opinion so the sage
is going to you know kind of have their
head on straight another thing that they
say that I think is is quite important
here is that progress procope is
possible or attainable in philosophy and
they say end philosophia right and in
other matters so procopene progress this
is something that gets discussed quite a
bit in ancient virtue ethics how do we
make progress what does progress
actually look like some denied that
progress could be made this school says
oh you can make progress all the time so
maybe you're only half a sage at this
point you can't screw up a lot of the
time but you're you're making progress
right so that's that's a possibility and
again we could look at the model that is
presented by aristipus as something that
would be perhaps an ideal to strive for
from the perspective of the Syrian ax
the other thing that we really have to
discuss is happiness or eudaimonia which
you know you can translate as other
things besides happiness uh you know
fulfillment living a good life literally
being of good spirit but happiness is
typically How We Do translate it and in
ancient philosophy this is what was
conceived of in different ways by the
different schools but it was something
that most uh ancient philosophers
thought we ought to aim at and they
conceptualize this in terms of the end
the Telos the the thing that we're
aiming at sometimes they also use the
word scopos the thing that literally we
have our eye on that we're aiming at
like a bullseye and a Target and the
good to agathon the thing that is good
for us
and interestingly the serenax
they make a distinction here it's not
happiness that's the good it's not
happiness that's the end
it's particular pleasures
particular and the word there that's
being translated literally means apart
or you know something that fits into
something else as well and there's a
couple different ways in which it gets
formulated here Kata tomeros hey donenen
pleasure that is in relation to a part
or
um
right a same sort of term there meros
means part compared to a holos a whole
and so happiness is the whole and all
the different Pleasures that we feel are
parts and this does tie in with the
notion of the sage back in that section
where they're talking about the wise
person uh there's this this Doctrine it
is sufficient even if we enjoy but each
single pleasure as it comes in the
presence we should not focus so much on
the future not worry so much about the
past we should think about the pleasures
that we can enjoy in the here and now
and we see that with aristipus it's said
about him that whatever situation he's
in he's looking for the pleasure that he
can find right there not worrying about
uh doing things that are conduced to
Pleasures down the line
now happiness you dimonia
is talked about as being a sum total
it's very interesting term that's used
here which does you know this arithmetic
notion does fit in given the other
things that are being said but the
literal word is sustaina uh Network a
system if you want to translate it you
know very literally a sum total of the
particular pleasures so the happiness
that we enjoy in our life is in fact the
you know organization of the different
Pleasures that we feel and he goes on uh
to say that the Syrian ax they total up
soon now that is a mathematical word
right
then you could say they they enumerate
and they enumerate together the Sun the
past and future Pleasures as well as the
pleasures of the present so you've got
on the one hand the present and the
present doesn't have to be just the
present moment I mean you could be
enjoying a candy bar for a couple
minutes right you could enjoy uh sexual
activity for an entire night you could
enjoy uh he talks about Pleasures like
you know taking pride in your country
yeah you could that could last for quite
a long time a mental pleasure like that
so the present isn't just this little
tiny moment right here but there is like
a present
I am currently uh 52 years old I had
many many Pleasures back as a teenager
and in my 20s those are definitely
passed right I I can remember going to a
party and you know drinking beer and and
uh you know talking with people having a
great conversation or uh doing head
banging to the metal music that was new
at the time that's all passed I can do
similar stuff in the present I can go to
a show now and see uh old rockers you
know rocking out in a crowd full of
mostly old people as well and that's a
present pleasure right and that's what I
can enjoy right now so you've got
present pleasures and then you've got
this vague conception of Happiness right
and the Syrian acts are saying um
go for the present Pleasures they they
go so far as to say that the
happiness this sum total or whatever we
want to call it uh is desirable
something that you would choose not for
its own sake but for the sake of the
particular pleasures
this is a big reversal in comparison to
how a lot of other schools view the good
the end happiness and the last thing
that's important to bring up here
is that the effort to try to be happy in
this respect can sometimes be
counterproductive so you know there's
this discussion
of Pleasures sometimes being of a
painful nature you know the things that
are productive of certain Pleasures
often are of a painful nature the very
opposite of pleasure so to accumulate
the pleasures which are productive of
Happiness right the things that we total
up into happiness seems to be this is a
good translation in irksome business
this is a
superlative the most irksome the most
pain in the rear uh kind of thing that
we have to do so you know maybe we
should not try so hard to be happy
according to the Sierra NAX In This Very
expansive sense and we should just try
to be happy with maybe a lowercase H uh
by enjoying the pleasures that we can
obtain easily and enjoy in the present
and that is what the wise person's life
for the Syrian ax is going to look like